[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 44th episode of chess trap
series
in this episode i am going to show you a
wonderful
high profile counter trap in the
sicilian dragon
from the black perspective
the critical position arises after the
few main line moves
e4 c5 knight to f3
d6 d4 c captures d4
knight captures d4 knight to f6
knight to c3 and now this trademark
dragon move
g6 okay
the main line continues with bishop to
e3
bishop to g7 f3
castle on the king side queen to d2
and now knight to c6
here white has two important main lines
the old and the most popular move in
this position is
bishop to c4 however in this episode
we are going to look at the modern
trendy line
starting with castle on the queen side
well d5 is by far most popular choice by
black
but recent theory suggests that black is
having some issues
and if you check my dirty chest tricks
against sicilian part
18 i have shown a nasty
napo nishi trick which by force
giving wide an opening advantage
so instead of that my recommendation
here is
you should continue with bishop to d7
which leads to the line in the normal
dragon territory
okay king to b1 a prophylaxis
getting the king out of the c file and
protecting
the a to pawn and now white is all set
to play the move g4 h4 a typical king
side expansion
and then launch a devastation to the
black king
okay no issues we are going to continue
with our dragon moves
rook to c8 g4
knight to e5 so that knight is going to
launch on the c4 square
but meantime white doesn't bother about
all this and he continued with his
normal attack with the move h4
well now comes the move which sets up a
cunning trap
and that is queen to a5
so as you can see i have highlighted by
the arrows
white has few options such as knight to
b3 or bishop to e2
however more often than not white
players
height will literally lit up as they can
come up with this
nasty tactical move knight to d5
so not only hitting the queen but there
is a threat of
knight captures e7 and if
black has to put the queen back to did
then
white attack will really crash on on the
king's side
so by force black has to exchange this
queen
but now white revealed his important
idea
namely in between move knight captures
e7 check and after king to etch it
and the move rook captures d2
if you count the material at this point
white
emerged with a clear pawn advantage
so no wonder many white players has
chosen this path
thinking that they are completely
winning
but guess what this is exactly the point
where
white has fallen into the black counter
trap
the real fun begins with rook to e8
and now even though white has three
options
all of them gives black a good advantage
first let me show you the main trap well
the natural move
knight to d5 is a big time disaster guys
and before we proceed i just like to
pause the video
and find the sequence where black is
coming on top
with a huge advantage
are you ready let's start the forcing
sequence start with
knight captures d5 pawn captures d5
and now this lovely move knight catches
f3
a double attack so by force
white has to take this knot but after
that
yup you guessed it rook captures e3
attacking the knight it doesn't matter
however wide support
let's say bishop to g2 the next turn
we are going to chop off on g4
and now if you count the material
not only black is a clear pawn up but
black has a two
raking bishop and by considering chess
engine analysis believe it or not
it gives black a huge plus to
advantage which is with the accurate
play
close to the winning
so this is one of the main trap if your
opponent continue with
blender move 16 knight to d5
the second move i want to consider is h5
which is in fact highestly played move
from this position
the point is if black foolishly take
this knight
then after at6 black bishop is a goner
and this position usually favor the
white cam
so obviously we are not going to fall
for it
rather we have the stunning reply here
as well
starting with knight e captures g4
bam
well what's the point what happens if
white take our piece
the answer is very simple knight
captures e4
not only attacking the rook but in the
next turn
we are going to take on e7 and again
black emerge with a material advantage
for example one of the game from the
database
continue with rook d2h2
chop up this knight and now white played
edge captures g6 which at first sight
looks very threatening but the black
player
who was the international master
continue
with this very accurate sequence
knight to g3 attacking two pieces
white gives some checks first
rook check then pawn check
but after rook captures 7 he realized
that
his rook is hanging as well as the
bishop
so he continued with bishop to c4
pinning down the black rogue but now
black
delivered the final blow knight captures
even
rook captures avon and now rook captures
e3
forcing white to resign the game as
clearly
there is no compensation for the loss of
the extra piece
last but not least what happens if you
opponent continue with
g5 which is in fact one of the best
reply
and against this my recommendation is
you should continue with this
very flashy move knight captures e4
once again white response is force he
has to take this knight
and after that we are going to take on
e7
and if you count the material at this
point yes
indeed it is balanced but the
big time problem arise in the near
future
as white e4 pawn is most likely a goner
and as i have highlighted over here
black has a very simple plan
to gobble up that weak bone
now to understand this point i like to
show you one of the game from the
database
where black finished the white very
quickly
white responded here with knight to b3
attacking on d6
and accordingly black counter-attack
with
bishop to c6
okay why defend it with bishop to g2
but missing the important point that is
knight to c4
well i think white was counting on all
this and he played the move rook to e2
and his idea is when white took the
spawn
he was relying on this important tactic
bishop captures a7 pinning down
the white bishop
but at the end it turned out that it was
a clear miscalculation
as black shows this forcing sequence
bishop captures g2 attacking two rooks
so white response is force he has to
take on g2
and now comes the sting in the tail
b6 trapping down that poor guy
in the corner white is in a desperate
situation
so he continued with rook to g4
attacking the knight but after knight to
e5
it is pretty clear that that piece
is going down rook to a4 happened
but after just one move rook to a8
it is confirmed that black counter trap
has been successfully employed in this
game
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile counter trap in the
sicilian dragon
remember if you open and continue with
knight to d5
thinking that he is going to win a pawn
well you should happily allow it with
queen captures d2
knight captures e7 king to h8 and now
rook captures d2
because at the end after rook to e8
as i have shown in this video no matter
however white plays it is
only black who will have all the fun
in upcoming game
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care